we have some really exciting official
news today about Keanu Reeves entering
the MCU finally how's it going everybody
it's Warren and there have been many
reports going around recently that Keanu
Reeves will be entering the MCU playing
a certain character the latest rounds of
rumors have said that he is going to be
playing a characters in the upcoming
movie the Eternals however we have
recently learned from none other than
the man himself Kevin Feige the
president of Marvel Studios that that is
not the only role that Keanu Reeves is
being considered for in fact he has been
considered for many different roles in
many different movies in the MCU and
this is coming from Kevin Feige the
president of Marvel Studios himself
there was a recent press junket in
London England for the release of
spider-man far from home and of course
Kevin Feige was there and during this
event comicbook.com asked Kevin Feige
about the recent Keanu Reeves and the
MCU rumors specifically in regards to
him being cast in the upcoming Eternals
movie here's what Brandon Davis of
comicbook.com said and asked Kevin Feige
in his one-on-one with him a couple of
actors I want to ask you about Keanu
Reeves you guys talking to him for
anything and listen to what Kevin Feige
had to say about Keanu Reeves being cast
as a character in an upcoming MCU movie
we talked to him for almost every film
we make I don't know when
if or ever he'll join the MCU but we
very much want to figure out the right
way to do it this is insanely awesome
news Marvel has not just been eyeing
Keanu Reeves for a role in the upcoming
Eternals movie but they have been eyeing
him in almost every single movie that
they've made and Kevin Feige went on to
say that this is the exact same thing
they did with Jake Gyllenhaal Kevin
Feige compared the casting of Keanu
Reeves to the casting of Jake Gyllenhaal
he said that they spoke to Jake
Gyllenhaal many different times about
many different characters until the
perfect role Mysterio came along and he
said that they're hoping the same
situation will occur for Keanu Reeves
he's hoping the perfect role for Keanu
Reeves will occur and that he can join
the wide world of the Marvel Cinematic
Universe so this is just incredibly
great news Marvel constantly talks to
Keanu Reeves about playing a character
in the MCU and Kevin Feige seems like
he's playing it pretty smooth he's
trying not to give anything away
especially since there are a lot of
reports going around that Keanu Reeves
has already been cast for a role in an
upcoming movie and it is important to
know how he answered this question about
other actors such as Milly Bobby Brown
and Donnie Yen when comicbook.com
asked about these other actors Kevin
Feige said that they're both good actors
and admitted they'd be fun to see in the
MCU but he also said that they have
nothing specific currently on the table
for them he answers this question very
differently than he answered the
question about Keanu Reeves he simply
said nothing is on the table for them
right now
so he's eyeing them but hasn't found
anything for them yet but that is
basically what he said the situation for
Keanu Reeves was right now although he
answered it very differently this means
that they're really trying to get Keanu
Reeves into the MCU as a character and
could possibly already have a role for
him we do know that after the Disney Fox
deal Kevin Feige is in charge of all the
x-men the Fantastic Four the Silver
Surfer Galactus gambit all of the
characters that are coming from Fox
Kevin Feige is in charge of there have
been talks of Keanu Reeves playing
Wolverine for a very long time now and
in a recent interview he did say that if
he could play any character in the MCU
he would want it to be Wolverine now of
course this doesn't mean that he will
play Wolverine but there are so many
different options now with all of the
characters back at Disney and Marvel
could he be Wolverine could he be in the
Fantastic Four that is rumored to be
coming out in 2020 could he be the
Silver Surfer there are so many
different options but the great news is
Marvel has confirmed that they are
trying to get him into an MCU movie very
soon as soon as that perfect character
role for him comes up so let me know
what you think about this news and be
sure to LIKE the video and comment with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero or villain and subscribe to my
channel so you can in chat the giveaway
and stay up to date on everything
relating to Marvel as always thank you
all so much for watching woof woof